[Music]  my name is patty high school was a  nightmare  patty Betty's huge while my classmates  were out losing their virginity I was at  home stuffing another hole it smells  like bacon every day I wondered how much  more of this can I take then it hit me  now what where's patty right here having  my jaw wired shut  lost me more than just my summer  vacation well this is like every great  high school movie ever made  now I could be the former fatty who  turned into a brain or an athlete or a  princess no I'd rather have revenge  [Applause]  [Music]  is out of control I want to punch her in  her [ __ ] face I want them to hurt like  I hurt it anymore  I was insatiable what can I say  this story is full of some crazy  that's what makes it so fun  [Music]  you